hey youtubers it's alright so really big
news just in the last couple days Ian
McShane has been announced as joining
the cast of Game of Thrones HBO hasn't
confirmed it but like a bunch of
legitimate news sites have so I'm just
taking it as fact at this point he is
joined but they saying it's going to be
a really small part but really critical
so there's all kinds of theories about
who he could be playing if you remember
I did a casting video where i listed a
bunch of characters that they were
trying to find most of those were major
roles like like there was a legendary
night with a legendary sword they were
looking for a lot of people are like
maybe that's how Arthur Dayne so maybe
ian mcshane is Arthur Dayne but I don't
think that's the case just because the
character that they're looking for
that's supposed to have that legendary
sword is supposed to be an amazing
swordsman in real life so like the
actual actor has to be really awesome
with a sword think think more like
Oberyn Martell dancing around with his
spear so Ian McShane doesn't seem like
the type to be really quick with a blade
that's why right now like my top three
choices for people that he could be
would be one he's the Mad King in a
Jamie flashback which would be you know
relatively minor role but very very
important scene in the history of a song
of ice and fire he could be someone else
inside that flashback he could be
Rickard stark ease about the right age
for that he was Ned Stark's father or
staying with the flashback theme he
could be Howland Reed who is it the big
Tower of joy encounter with Ned Stark
Lyanna stark and Arthur Dayne
realistically think think about how old
Ian McShane is right now like this is a
current picture of him right right now
even though you know Game of Thrones
might make him look a little bit younger
they're not going to like you see g2d hm
so he'll be playing a character that is
comparable to his real-life age a lot of
people are wondering if he's the mystery
pirate the game of thrones is trying to
cast the Euron Greyjoy character that I
mean everyone thinks it's your uncle a
joy so I'm just using that name the
problem with that is is that I think
that that character is going to be a
little bit younger like ian mcshane
looks even older than the actor that
played Balon Greyjoy and that wouldn't
really sync up with the with the ages
the characters are cast at Jaime
Lannister's Cersei Lannister even though
they're like in their mid-30s in the
books they're in their mid 40s on the
show like the show ages everyone up
about ten years just because they want
to have like these Tom and Marjorie
scenes and it only
works if everybody gets aged up the
other big possibility is that he could
be playing samwell's father randyll
Tarly now a lot of people are pointing
out that randyll Tarly is supposed to be
a major role but the thinking is is that
you know you know maybe he plays randyll
Tarly and he's only on screen for a
little while in season 6 and then
becomes a bigger character in season
seven if randyll Tarly is going to be a
major character in season six seven and
eight they definitely didn't shy around
his character too much during season
five Stannis Baratheon black meanest
person ever even complimented Samwell on
his father's battle prowess despite the
fact that randyll Tarly fought against
him during Robert's rebellion we no
randyll Tarly is coming to the show we
just we don't know how old are going to
cast the actor so just add that to the
top of the list along with the Mad King
honestly I think he might be a little
too old to play Hal and read too because
Howland Reed would be of a comparable
age to Ned Stark in Sean Bean does not
look anywhere close to the same age is
ian mcshane i mean sean bean is no
spring chicken anymore but it's like you
can only age actors down so much without
using CG and that's not what game of
thrones does like they don't cg actors
ages down they just cast like really
really young versions of them like the
Circe flashback just to lay a little
context for Jamie flashback possibly to
the Mad King you know just because it's
a really important time in his life it
was like a big turning point for the
kingdom I think it would be amazing
foreshadowing for what's happening in
King's Landing in like the next couple
seasons most notably with Cersei like
think about it this way Joffrey was like
the closest thing to the Mad King he's
already dead so they're there wouldn't
be a lot of context for that but what
did Jamie were forced to make the same
type of choice that he made with the Mad
King now I did a Jamie history video so
I'll add a link for that in the
description but when you read the book
he kind of explains his thought process
as to like how he came to the decision
that he needed to kill the Mad King it
was only a measure of last resort he
told the story to bran when they were
taking the bath together and it's pretty
close to what was in his POV chapters in
the books when he's talking about when
he killed the Mad King but the books
have a little bit more time to explain
it so there's just a little more context
you get the sense that like he was he
was at the end of his rope and he's a
fairly rational person even though he's
very selfish so what if he were
presented with similar circumstances
like Cersei starts spiraling out of
control look at this look on her face at
the end of season 5 she looks like she
is cooking up some terrible plan of
revenge now we just need to say like she
is nowhere near as crazy as the Mad King
was the Mad King was called the Mad King
for a reason and even though they
haven't said it on the show like Jamie
was forced to guard his room while he
heard him raping his wife Raila
Targaryen remember Targaryen marry
inside the family so think about how
Jamie deals with no-win situations and
what kind of no-win situation the show
might present him with in season six
seven or eight now just to be clear Lena
Headey is one of the main actors on the
show she's one of HBO's main attractions
I don't think we're anywhere close to
the narrative telling us that Jamie is
going to run sir see through there's way
too much for him to deal with right now
with marcella dying this stuff going on
with door and Circe's trial like he's
not just gonna like turn around in the
next six episodes and run her through if
it ever did come to that they would
probably push that to like season eight
I mean they would save that for the last
season but just to give you more Ian
McShane context if you guys have HBO now
access or if you have access to HBO on
demand or anything like that re watch
some Deadwood with ian mcshane he is so
much the Mad King I mean that's not the
character that he plays on Deadwood but
his character does have a certain regal
bearing even though it's the Wild West
say what you're gonna say a Rickard
stark or prepare for effing eternal
silence seriously I don't think it's
possible for a group of characters to
swear more than they swore on Deadwood
especially calamity jane i mean dead was
just a great series so you should check
it out anyway but he is both the perfect
deadbeat dad so I mean he just he's
perfect for Sam wells father for randyll
Tarly just because he has this
commanding presence and he you know he
would be older at this point in the
series or the Mad King those are really
my top two choices but just remember his
role is supposed to be very minor very
important in season six but that doesn't
say that he's not coming back in season
seven if it does turn out to be a
flashback then it probably will be the
only time that we see him for example
like I'm not expecting to see young sir
see again but how great would it be to
get like it like a Jamie flashback scene
I know a lot of people want him to be
the Vallum car the person that Maggy the
Frog prophesied would end up killing
Cersei
a lot of people logically thought that
would be Tyrion but it would be more
poetic if it was Jamie one of the few
people who actually loved her jamie is
the Oathbreaker so in in the fan fiction
that I will write he kills Cersei with
oathkeeper but that's just like way too
hammy for the show to ever do that's
like pure fanfiction territory let me
know though if Jamie were to ever kill
sir see how would you want him to do it
maybe push her out the tower window
Winterfell that that would be that would
be pretty cool I could see them doing
that is like a parody video on SNL so
not you guys turn just let me know every
single theory you have about who ian
mcshane is going to be playing on the
show you know Howland Reed Mad King
randyll Tarly and a lot of people are
still going to wonder about your on
Greyjoy but I feel like that character
is going to be younger on the show and
new round of the giveaway starts now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'm going to be doing a Q&A video
that all announce the winner in it in
the giveaway in my last video is still
going on too so there's actually a
double giveaway right now the funny news
that I saw it at Belfast is is that the
government wants HBO to leave the wall
set up so they could turn it into a
tourist attraction once the show is over
and it's a great idea a lot of people
like to visit Game of Thrones sets but
what's going to happen if the White
Walkers tear down the wall during the
war for the dawn any time a bunch of
characters point to something and say
look how huge that is it's almost
invincible nothing's getting through of
course something has to eventually get
through it has to come crashing down if
that were the case HBO might just
arrange to rebuild part of the wall
afterwards and when you think about it I
mean most of that would be like a CG
effect anyway they're actually shooting
the show right now there's been some
pictures from this set it's up in and
around where the veil scenes take place
there aren't any main actors on set and
there's some northern Lords the show is
trying to cast their not on set either
just just because they haven't been cast
yet so we're still in like early early
stages of filming so what's going to
happen next is is because I talked about
a whole bunch of characters that I
haven't done bonus videos for yet like
the Mad King and Hal and read those will
be like the next bonus character videos
that I do why you has wait for that you
can click here to learn all about Jaime
Lannister's history especially what
happened in and around Robert's
rebellion and you can click here to
learn all about Game of Thrones eighth
season plan
and the prequel that they've been
talking about it's supposedly george RR
martin said it's duncan egg is what's in
discussion right now thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow